it started as a legend one of the  greatest of all thousand years who've  kept it hidden to protect Earth from  what was destined to arrive Optimus  Prime you destroyed your home he's the  Prudential money maker I do  [Music]  your daughter what would you say to her  Oh shooty 20 point a band especially a  drummer  these are trouble times without leaders  chaos reigns  two worlds colliding  you're all that stand in its way now the  greatest mission of them all to turn the  tide of human history  I can't do it  [Applause]  the illness destruction of everything we  know and love begins  I'm not leaving you  my no screams lost a few brave souls  [Music]  everything you've ever known the  operations over when I keep it up a  bribe okay  I'm escaped  and it once I said  [Music]  or my will to live  yours must die  you  [Music]  you